[Music]
this isn't your regular hot chocolate
this is hot chocolate with chai please
don't call this chai tea hot chocolate
it's just chai hot chocolate get it
right
Starbucks
wow 1 and 1/2 cup of milk two black tea
bags in there now you want to put it on
the stove and let it come to boil let it
boil for about 3 minutes then cut off
the heat take out the tea bags then
we're going to let this cool down for
about 10 minutes then we're going to get
our strainer and sip through a teaspoon
of corn starch and a teaspoon of cacao
powder now we're going to turn on the
heat to medium low stir that in then
we're going to put in 1/4 cup heavy
cream now we're going to put in 4 oz of
chocolate now we're going to let this
fully melt down add in some marshmallows
and toast it up did you really think I
was going to forget about the Thai Chili
Pepper honey of course you can use
regular honey